in a previous video we asked ourselves a
very important question as the moon has
its 28-day cycle around the earth we
talked about how a new moon is when the
moon is between the Earth and the Sun
and so from the Earth's point of view or
support from the point of view of
someone standing on earth you're seeing
the side of the moon that is not lit up
but an obvious question is is why
doesn't that block out the Sun every
time we are in a new moon position after
all the Sun would be out here 93 million
miles away and so wouldn't the moon
block out the Sun in that scenario and
we also talked about when the moon is on
the other side of the earth when we
would typically see a full moon the
earth is between the moon and the Sun
why doesn't the earth block the light
from the Sun that's being reflected on
the moon so the big question is why
don't we see a solar eclipse every new
moon and why don't we see a lunar
eclipse every full moon if we want to
ask the same question looking at the
scale of the earth in the moon we can
see it right over here and so this would
be the new moon position where the moon
is between the Earth and the Sun the key
explanation for why we do not have a
solar eclipse every time we are in the
new moon position is that the rotation
of the Moon around the earth is not in
the exact same plane as the rotation of
the earth around the Sun it actually
turns out that the plane of the moon's
rotation is at a 5 degree angle with the
plane of the earth and the Sun if this
is the Sun here and this is not drawn to
scale by any means this is the earth and
so the earth is in its orbit something
like that the moon's orbit does not sit
exactly in this plane it does not sit
exactly in this plane the moon's orbit
is that a 5 degree angle is that a 5
degree angle to this plane so depending
what time of year you are at and where
the moon is in its cycle the moon will
often sit above or below the plane of
the Earth's orbit so for example from
the vantage point of the
earth the moon will vary up to five
degrees above the plane of Earth's
rotation around the Sun often known as
the ecliptic and five degrees below that
and so you can see here the shadow of
the moon will only fall on the earth
when the moon is crossing through the
plane of the rotation of Earth around
the Sun many times the moon might be
here or here or here and in those times
the shadow will not hit the earth now
what you do see here depicted in this
picture would be a solar eclipse now
there's two things that I've drawn here
and this is important for understanding
a solar eclipse what you see those
yellow lines
that's the Umbra of the moon so if you
are in if you're at that point right
over here in this picture then the moon
will completely block out the Sun it
turns out depending on the solar eclipse
where that Umbra is hitting the earth it
might only be a few hundred miles where
the moon completely blocks out the Sun
what do you see in this dark blue color
that is the pen Umbra that is the outer
shadow and if you're in one of those
areas you will see the moon partially
block out the Sun now this is the exact
same reason the fact that the plane of
its rotation is at a five degree angle
with the plane of rotation of the earth
around the Sun that's the reaso the
reason why we don't see a lunar eclipse
every 28 days here we see different
scenarios where the moon is on the other
side of Earth from the Sun when the moon
is what we would call a full moon
position and as we can see it can vary
five degrees above the plane of the
earth and the Sun or five degrees below
that and you're only going to get a
scenario of a lunar eclipse when the
moon happens to fall in the shadow of
the earth and here once again between
the yellow lines you see the Umbra and
between the blue lines you see the pen
number which would be kind of a partial
shadow so next time you look up at the
moon hopefully you are armed with a
more information to think about how its
oriented with respect to the earth in
fact now when you look at the moon at
night you can usually look at the moon
and tell which direction the Sun is in
and based on that you can even think
about what time of day it is and you
could figure out east west north in
south
and we've talked a lot about the Sun in
fact this entire video and the one
before it is all about light from the
Sun and just to finish off with a little
bit of awe let's just appreciate how
large and how far the Sun is as we
mentioned before this is a scaled
representation of the earth and the moon
the moon being roughly 240,000 miles
away from Earth if we were to try to
model the Sun here it is 400 times as
far depending on your screen size it
would be a football field to the right
of your screen and you would have
something roughly the size of a beach
ball to represent the Sun if you wanted
to just compare the sizes of the Sun to
the earth in the moon here you go the
Sun is huge